Joe Biden's campaign is unfortunately for
him increasingly going over like a lead balloon,
disastrous results in Iowa coming in fourth
after polling a second in Iowa, he's down
to fourth place in the polls for the New Hampshire
primary, which is tomorrow.
And then over the weekend, Joe Biden called
a female voter, a dog faced pony soldier.
Last week we talked about Joe Biden, strange
sort of overly aggressive behavior, uh, with
some male voters poking them in the chest,
telling them to go vote for somebody else.
This time it's a female voter.
Check out this video she asks about the Iowa
results.
Biden asks if she's ever participated in a
caucus and she says yes, and he calls her
dog faced.
Um, so you're arguably the candidate with
greatest advantage in this race.
You've been, the vice president weren't burdened
down by the impeachment styles so early in
the participant.
So how do you explain the performance in Iowa
and why should the voters believe that you
can win the national election?
That's a good question.
Number one, right?
I was a democratic caucus.
The remainder of caucus.
No, you haven't.
You're alive.
Dog face pony soldier.
You said you are now.
You gotta be honest.
I'm going to be honest with you.
I guess this is apparently some kind of joke
making fun of the caucus process, which believe
me, the caucus process deserves plenty of
ridicule, but this is not a good look.
This is actually not even the first time Joe
Biden has used this term.
He did it at a rally in 2018 for Senator Heidi
Heitkamp and he referred to the line as being
from a John Wayne movie.
Check it out.
This seems to be the origin of Biden using
this phrase.
I had my brother who loves me to use lines
from movies, a John Wayne movie.
There's a big line in the movie, John, we
remember the Indian chief turns to John Wayne
and says, it's a lion dog face pony soldier.
Well, let me tell ya, these guys are amazing.
Now a bunch of people looked up that line.
They tried to find that line in a John Wayne
movie and they weren't able to.
So as I've said before, I would vote for Joe
Biden in a second over Donald Trump if Biden
is the nominee.
But we can't just write this stuff off as
generational.
Bernie Sanders is 14 months older than Joe
Biden, and he's not constantly saying this
type of stuff.
You could say, well, culturally, you know,
Bernie's from a Jewish New York family, it's
a different world.
They might as well be from different planets
all together culturally compared to what Biden
grew up around.
Okay.
Elizabeth Warren is only seven years younger
than Biden, and she also isn't saying this
stuff and she's from Oklahoma and lived in
Texas for awhile.
Whatever calling women dog faced is just bad,
even if it's part of whatever Joe Biden thinks
a dog faced pony soldier refers to from a
John Wayne movie that nobody is able to find.
I am up for believing that this was a joke
and simply one that nobody understood and
there was no ill intention behind it.
I won't even argue with you.
I'm still asking how do you make it to the
convention?
If you're calling voters dog faced when they
ask reasonable questions like, what the hell
happened to your results in Iowa, and then
you tell them to vote for somebody else when
they come up and say, Hey, will you get us
off fossil fuels or whatever the case may
be.
We're seeing Joe Biden's campaign and plode
on a daily basis ending up forth in Iowa after
polling second, going from polling first in
New Hampshire to polling fourth as of right
now with voting tomorrow and the way things
have gone, I wouldn't be shocked to see him
end up fifth with Klobuchar in fourth place
in New Hampshire.
It's early.
We don't know, unclear in Nevada and South
Carolina what's going on because we have infrequent
polling there.
He was doing well there.
Uh, but who knows what's going on.
Now, falling from first to second behind in
California, barely holding a lead in Texas
where he had been leading for a long time.
I just don't see how he can hold it together
through the DNC, nevermind through a general
election campaign against Donald Trump.
If he's the nominee, I will vote for him against
Trump and I will have it, no doubt that he
is the better option.
Joe Biden over Donald Trump.
Increasingly it's feeling unlikely given his
performance, but it's important not to underestimate
the power of some super Tuesday wins just
three weeks from now.
And of course the DNC is going to have to
decide do they, do they keep pushing Biden?
Have they switched to Buddha judge, will they
go to Bloomberg?
If Bloomberg does well on super Tuesday where
he is focusing essentially all of his resources,
let me know what you make about all of this.
I do want to hear from you.
We will take a quick break
and so much more coming up today including
an analysis of the value added.
Pat, we're going to dig into the value added
tax right after this.